Tên chủ uống dùng xa bang đập vỡ cửa kính đột nhập tiếp nèo lúc sạng sáng
lấy đi nhiều tại sang chỉ trong vai phút. Theo camera an ninh khoảng bột dờ bây triến phút ngày
mấy lắm tháng năm khi tiếp nèo tại Up by sả thử bình đã đông cửa và bên trong không có người
2 năm tinh nhân xuất hiện chức gở tiếp. Một người đi tới dùng dây bột cơ nhà dân cách đó hướng
mề mết rồi ngoài lại xe người con lại đứng chức gở kính lên tục quán xa bên trong.
Sau ai phút sò sét, người này bất gờ dùng xa bang đập mạnh khiến cơ kính vỡ tùng rồi nhến chống chui vào bên trong tiếp. Tên chủng gì chuyện nhanh quá cuối cuối cuối,
lên tục kéo các khu vụ tụ để tình tài sản. Nhưng anh tụi bị dịch mạnh dều lên mấy bông xa, trong lúc lúc lúc lỗi,
hắn lên tục ngoái nhìn sang rãi rồi tiếp tục tìm kiếm ở các vị trí khác. Sau hơn 2 phút, nhóm này lại đi để thoại,
tên mặt, loa kéo kéo cộng một số dụ cụ lắm nghe rồi dời khỏi hình chưa?
Tên nằm nhé mà gàm lên trong những tỏi nước mẹ người là phát hiện nằm dạch dạy xuống như coi, có chính người mà là một cái hồi,
thì kính nó nổ xuống như tổ hiện nó lộn mất đứng hỏi,
tình, dụng có lần nghe cũng tảy gách thật, tại nhiên cũng mắt tệ mà, tài xuất tệm.
Tại nhiên là đầu có gì đến lấy tầu, mình cũng có nghe có ná đây dụ chạy đó,
trả mà tỏ lệm không dám hủ lụng như phát tự cà mà, nhưng có hồi hình có hả hình.
Theo chủ tiếp, tồng sẽ chỉ tài sản bị mất lên mười chữ đâu.